foreign
Missouri hey Mark welcome to the show
today what are y'all up to just
struggling through man how can we help I
I understand hey me and my wife here
we're kind of quick and cleaning a lot
of stuff and we're needing to ask a
question okay
we're twitched in between step five and
six and our gazelle he's kind of sitting
in the thicket there catching his breath
a little bit and we was wondering which
way to point him and how hard to kick
him
oh you got dialed in man I like it well
what we tell folks is you do gazelle
intensity which is scorched Earth no
life a hundred percent game on in baby
steps one through three so when I tell
you what we have crossed the thing and
you did that you did that yeah you got
through and now uh now you've got your
emergency phone in place and you're debt
free and you're doing baby steps four
five and six simultaneously and we tell
folks when you go when you do that we uh
we do sideline the gazelle uh we move
from intense to intentional
right from a Sprint to a marathon
we're still running our girls are yeah
our girls are fixing to get out of
school and May and we'll have them
through school so they'll be done with
that got them off the page
yeah they're they'll be done off the
payroll and gone good and basically we
got about 170 000 left on our farm and
then we'll then we'll be done done yeah
and so intentional looks intentional
looks like this yes if you need to
upgrade your couch that's going to slow
down the paying down on the farm by the
amount of the couch yes we're going to
go on vacation mama needs one and uh
that's going to slow down the paying
down on the farm but we're not going to
consume so many things that we don't do
anything towards getting rid of that
farm debt but we're also not doing beans
and rice rice and beans gazelle
intensity at this stage and having no
life this is the stage where we have a
life but we're careful about it and
intentional so that we still accomplish
those other goals as well so you move
from intense to intentional
that sounds that sounds better than what
we've been doing
but hey here's the thing Mark you you're
gonna have to practice it because you're
not going to be any good idea we ain't
really used we ain't really used to it
no because that means here's what it
means in the past for the past few years
you don't have a conversation about the
couch and just know we're paying off
debt now you and your wife gonna have to
have a conversation about a couch and
that's a skill set that most married
couples don't have and so we're gonna
practice it we're going to practice
where do you want to go for vacation how
big is it going to be and how small is
it going to be you're going to more than
we spend on that the less we can put on
the farm that's right and there's an
expensive tension there if you don't
have tension something's weird you're
gonna have tension there and that's part
of the deal you will always have tension
because you always have a limited amount
of money
no one has unlimited money and an
unlimited amount of I wish we could yeah
there's always a there's always a list
and it's always longer than the money
um and so it doesn't matter and it's
like the list does get more fun of
course because the stuff on it is much
cooler when you've got some money but uh
it's still a list and there's still some
things we're going to do right now and
some things we're not going to do right
now and you got to make those four
forced ranked decisions as a couple
there's I I wonder Dave if it's just
sometimes easier I I I've never thought
this I'm thinking saying it out loud so
catch me if I'm wrong here but in some
ways it's easier just to take off
running just a scorched Earth it does
because it's it's simple it's singular
focused and so you don't burn hardly any
mental calories the answers Note
Everything the answer is no to
everything except paying off debt right
and so it's you don't have to stop and
think about it yeah there's no no no
it's hard to decide what goes in
retirement what goes on vacation because
when you back up and you go okay I'm now
now I'm con yes we can do that
but do we want to now that burns some
calories that's right that takes up some
mental anguish I never put that together
before yeah